LIKE.
>> SO GRATEFUL WE HAVE YOU
ESPECIALLY ON DAYS LIKE TODAY.
THANK YOU.
>>> JOINING US IS FORMER TRUMP
TERN TIMOTHY PAL TORI.
EVAN REPORTED THAT MARK MEADOWS
HAS BEEN ASKED ABOUT CLASSIFIED
DOCUMENTS AND JANUARY 6th.
WHAT WOULD HE HAVE TESTIFIED
ABOUT, YOUR -- I GUESS MY
QUESTION IS ARE YOU CONCERNED
THAT MARK MEADOWS TESTIFYING TO
A GRAND JURY OR WOULD HIS
CURRENT LEGAL TEAM BE CONCERNED
GIVEN THE SCALE OF HIS KNOWLEDGE
ABOUT THE FORMER PRESIDENT AND
HIS TIME?
>> WELL, YOU KNOW, CERTAINLY
WHEN I WAS A MEMBER OF THE TEAM
I WASN'T CONCERNED ABOUT ANY OF
THESE WITNESSES BECAUSE WHILE WE
CERTAINLY DID FIGHT ISSUES OF
PRIVILEGE TO MAKE SURE THAT
THOSE THINGS ARE MAINTAINED, OUR
POSITION ALWAYS WAS AS LONG AS
EVERYBODY TELLS THE TRUTH, THAT
IS THE BEST DEFENSE.
SO IF MARK MEADOWS WENT IN AND
TOLD EVERYTHING AS ACTUALLY
HAPPENED, I THINK THAT THAT'S
GOING TO BE PERFECTLY FINE.
>> COULD I FOLLOW UP ON THAT?
BETWEEN TEXT MESSAGES THAT WE
HAVE ALL SEEN BECAUSE THEY WERE
REVEALED BY THE COMMITTEE
BETWEEN STAFFERS THAT HAVE BEEN
AROUND HIM, I THINK THERE WERE A
LOT OF QUESTIONS RAISED ABOUT
WHETHER OR NOT ON SEVERAL FRONTS
MARK MEADOWS HAD INFORMATION OR
WAS AWARE OF INFORMATION OR WAS
IN ROOMS TIED TO INFORMATION
THAT WOULD PRESENT POTENTIAL
LEGAL JEOPARDY NOT JUST FOR HIM,
BUT ALSO POTENTIALLY FOR THE
FORMER PRESIDENT AS WELL.
YOU WERE SAYING EXPLICITLY NOT
POSSIBLE.
THERE IS ABSOLUTELY NOTHING MARK
MEADOWS COULD HAVE SAID OR KNOWN
ABOUT THAT WOULD BE PROBLEMATIC?
>> NO.
WHAT I'M SAYING IS BASED ON THE
INFORMATION THAT I HAVE, IF HE
GOES IN AND TELLS THE TRUTH AS
HIS LAWYER SAID THAT HE DID,
THEN HE IS GOING TO BE ABLE TO
PLACE ALL THESE THINGS IN
CONTEXT SO THAT PEOPLE CAN
UNDERSTAND THAT THERE IS AN
EXPLANATION FOR THESE THINGS
THAT IS VERY DIFFERENT FROM WHAT
THE PUBLIC NARRATIVE HAS BEEN.
>> HOW DO YOU EXPLAIN DEFYING A
SUBPOENA AND KEEPING CLASSIFIED
DOCUMENTS?
>> WELL, WHO DEFIED A SUBPOENA?
YOU KNOW, THE --
>> MORE THAN 100 DOCUMENTS --
>> AS A -- SURE.
WELL, FIRST OF ALL, IF WE LOOK
AT THE ACTUAL EVIDENCE IN THIS
CASE AS OPPOSED TO SOME OF THE
LEAKED PUBLIC NARRATIVE, WHAT
HAPPENED WAS A SUBPOENA WAS
ISSUED, A CERTAIN PERIOD OF TIME
IS GIVEN FOR COMPLIANCE,
ADDITIONAL TIME IS REQUESTED.
THE ADDITIONAL TIME NEEDED WAS
NOT GRANTED.
EVAN DID THE SEARCH THAT HE WAS
ABLE TO WITHIN THE PERIOD OF
TIME THAT HE WAS GIVEN.
HE GAVE A CERTIFICATION SAYING
THIS IS WHAT I FOUND DURING THAT
DILIGENT CINCH.
ACTUALLY SIGNED BY BOB.
AND THEN WHEREAS, NORMALLY YOU
WOULD HAVE INFORMATIONS WITH DOJ
ABOUT CONTINUING SEARCHES, YOU
KNOW, THEY WOULD -- YOU KNOW,
ANY TIME I TALK WITH A U.S.
ATTORNEY THEY WOULD SAY GIVE US
WHAT YOU CAN WITHIN THAT PERIOD
OF TIME BUT WE'D LIKE YOU TO
KEEP SEARCHING.
THAT DIDN'T HAPPEN.
JAY BRANDT CUT IT OFF AND SAID,
NO, DO EVERYTHING BY THIS DATE.
HE GAVE EVERYTHING HE COULD BY
THAT DATE AND THEN THERE WAS NO
CONTINUED CONVERSATIONS AS THEY
WOULD BE WITH ANY PROFESSIONAL
U.S. ATTORNEY'S OFFICE.
ANY SUBSEQUENT SERVES THAT WERE
AFTER THE TIME PERIOD IN WHICH
EVAN HAD TO SEARCH, A LOT OF
THAT COULD HAVE BEEN AVOIDED
THROUGH, YOU KNOW, NORMAL
INTERACTIONS.
YOU KNOW, THIS IS SOMETHING THAT
WE DO ALL THE TIME.
ELIE HONIG AND I THIS A CASE
YEARS AGO, WE WORKED WELL
TOGETHER THESE TYPES OF THINGS.
THAT IS NOT HOW THIS DOJ TEAM
HANDLED IT.
THEY CREATE THIS SITUATION WHERE
YOU CAN THEN SAY THEY IGNORED A
SUBPOENA, BUT THAT'S NOT THE
REALITY WHEN YOU GET DOWN TO THE
BRASS TACKS OF THE ACTUAL FACTS
HERE.
>> I WANT TO PLAY FOR YOU, GIVEN
THAT POINT, AND THIS HAS BEEN A
CONSISTENT POINT YOU AND SOME OF
THE CURRENT LEGAL TEAM MADE, YOU
SOUND FROM THE FORMER ATTORNEY
GENERAL, BILL BARR, OBVIOUSLY,
IN THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION.
TAKE A LISTEN.
>> I THINK OVER TIME PEOPLE WILL
SEE THAT THIS IS NOT A CASE OF
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE, YOU
KNOW, CONDUCTING A WITCH HUNT.
THEY APPROACHED THIS VERY
DELICATELY AND WITH DEFERENCE TO
THE PRESIDENT AND THIS WOULD
HAVE GONE NOWHERE HAD THE
PRESIDENT JUST RETURNED THE
DOCUMENTS.
HE JERKED THEM AROUND FOR A YEAR
AND A HALF.
THE GO QUESTION IS, DID HE
DECEIVE THEM?
>> THAT'S THE DISSONANCE BETWEEN
WHAT YOU ARE LAYING OUT.
BILL BARR IS NOT SOMEBODY WHO
WOULD WANT TO TAKE DOWN THE
FORMER PRESIDENT.
WHAT IS YOUR RESPONSE TO THAT?
>> SURE.
THAT'S A GREAT WORD YOU USED,
DISSONANCE, BECAUSE THERE IS
WITH THIS CASE AND MANY CASES A
DISSONANCE BETWEEN WHAT IS
ACTUALLY HAPPENED, WHAT THE FULL
FACTS ARE, AND WHAT SELECTED
PORTIONS GET PUT OUT INTO THE
PUBLIC SPHERE.
BILL BARR IS MAKING A COMMENT
BASED ON THE INFORMATION HE HAS
BEEN PROVIDED WHICH IS
DEFINITELY NOT EVERYTHING.
IT'S CERTAINLY NOT IN CONTEXT.
AND IT'S ONE OF THE REASONS WHY
I HAVE BEEN WILLING TO COME OUT
AT THIS TIME.
I AM A FORMER MEMBER OF THE
TEAM.
I AM NOT HERE TO DEFEND THE
PRESIDENT.
I AM HERE TO ANSWER REQUEST KEGS
ABOUT, YOU KNOW, WHAT THE FACTS
ARE TO THE EX TENLTD I CAN SAY
LEGALLY AND WHAT THE ACTUAL LAW
IS AS OPPOSED TO TO THE SPIN
GOING ON.
>> WE LEARNED THERE IS A SECOND
GRAND JURY IN THESE PROBES IN
FLORIDA.
THERE ARE VENUE QUESTIONS,
RIGHT?
THIS IS LEGALLY A PART OF AN
ALLEGED CRIME HAS TO HAVE
HAPPENED WITH A GRAND JURY IS
CONVENED.
WHAT ARE YOUR THOUGHTS ON THE
FACT THAT A KEY WITNESS WE KNOW
GOING BEFORE THE GRAND JURY
TODAY, I BELIEVE.
I UNDERSTAND THAT FLORIDA MAY BE
A MORE DESIRABLE JURY POOL FOR
THE PRESIDENT'S LEGAL TEAM.
CORRECT ME IF I'M WRONG.
WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF THE FACT
THAT THERE IS A SECOND GRAND
JURY IN FLORIDA?
>> WELL, YOU KNOW, I WOULD
ACTUALLY PUT IT IN THE INVERSE,
THAT D.C. IS A MORE FAVORABLE
JURY POOL FOR WHAT JACK SMITH
WANTS.
THEY STARTED THAT INVESTIGATION
IN D.C.
THEY HAVE HAD ALL THESE
WITNESSES BEFORE THE D.C. GRAND
JURY WITHOUT EVER REALLY
EXAMINING IS THERE VENUE IN D.C.
AND SO I INTERPRET THIS ACTION
AS THEM GETTING DOWN TO THE END
TRYING TO MAKE A DECISION AND
SAYING, UH-OH, WE TOTALLY FORGOT
ONE OF THESE THRESHOLD ISSUES
AND, YOU KNOW, NOW THEY HAVE TO
KIND OF GO BACK AND FIX A LOT OF
THE MISTAKES THAT THEY MADE.
YOU KNOW, IF THIS WAS SOMETHING
WHERE THEY WERE GOING TO DO A
GRAND JURY INVESTIGATION AND
ULTIMATELY JUST ISSUE A REPORT
AS OPPOSED TO AN INDICTMENT,
THEN THERE IS NO COURT IN WHICH
WE WOULD BE CHALLENGING THE
SUFFICIENCY OF ANY, YOU KNOW,
VENUE OR, YOU KNOW, WHETHER A
WARRANT WAS PROPERLY ISSUED OR
ANYTHING LIKE THAT.
AND IF THEY ARE ACTUALLY
CONSIDERING NOW, YOU KNOW, TO GO
THE INDICTMENT ROUTE, THEY HAVE
TO GO BACK AND FIX A LOT OF THE
MISTAKES.
AND DON'T FORGET THIS IS AN
INVESTIGATION THAT STARTED
BEFORE JACK SMITH GOT INVOLVED.
THE NATIONAL SECURITY DIVISION
AS OPPOSED TO THE CRIMINAL
DIVISION STARTED IN MAY OF LAST
YEAR.
SO NOW THAT THEY HAVE MORE OF
THE PROFESSIONAL EXPERIENCED
CRIMINAL PROSECUTORS ON THE CASE
THEY HAVE TO GO BACK AND FIX
THINGS.
>> WE DON'T HAVE A LOT OF TIME
LEFT.
DID YOU RAISE WHILE YOU WERE
THERE ISSUES OF VENUE TO THE
SPECIAL COUNSEL'S TEAM TO JACK
SMITH AT ANY POINT?
>> UNFORTUNATELY YOUR QUESTION
PRESUPPOSES THAT WE HAD ACTUAL
CONVERSATIONS WITH THAT TEAM.
IT WAS NOT SOMETHING THAT THEY
WERE REALLY OPEN TO HAVING
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT ANYTHING
WITH US.
AT LEAST WHILE I WAS THERE.
>> THAT'S A NO?
>> NO.